Schafgarbe, strahlenlose Kamille oder Beifuß
– in weiten Teilen Deutschlands
und Europas werden diese Pflanzen
oft als störend empfunden.
Sie werden vernichtet und entsorgt
– oft einfach aus Unwissenheit.
Doch wer sich, wie Peter Franke,
mit Wildkräutern auskennt,
findet in der Natur schmackhafte
Zutaten zum Kochen.
Umgangssprachlich „Wildkräuter“
und das Schimpfwort dazu ist „Unkräuter“,
was total fehl am Platze ist.
Ich glaube, wir sollten diese „Unkräuter“
richtig hochleben lassen.
Deswegen müssen wir die Wertigkeit der
Kräuter in den Mittelpunkt stellen,
welche guten Eigenschaften sie haben.
Denn Wildkräuter sind gesund.
Manche liefern weit mehr Vitamine und
Mineralstoffe als so manches Gemüse.
Peter Franke sammelt sie auf Wiesen und
Feldern in der Umgebung von Werben,
einem kleinen Ort mitten im Spreewald,
im Osten Deutschlands.
Ich freue mich über die
Schafgarbe das ganze Jahr,
die mach ich so ab und
nehm ich für die Butter,
für den Quark,
Trocknen als Tee,
als Bad
und natürlich
das Beste, was ich daraus mache,
ist mein Magenbitter.
Essbare Wildkräuter
eignen sich hervorragend
für das Zubereiten vieler Speisen.
Zusammen mit Daniel Noack,
einem seiner Köche,
bereitet er für sein Gasthaus ein
Pesto auf Brennnessel-Basis zu.
Dafür verwenden sie nicht nur die Blätter.
Wichtig ist bei der Brennnessel,
dass man den weiblichen Samen nimmt.
Das ist das beste Nahrungsergänzungsmittel.
Hier sind alle Inhaltsstoffe drinnen.
Zu dem leicht nussigen Geschmack der
Brennnessel passen geröstete Walnüsse.
Für eine gute Konsistenz wird
alles mit Rapsöl vermengt
und mit dem Mörser zerstoßen.
Und fertig ist das Pesto.
Wildkräuter eignen sich auch für Salate.
Die Köche nehmen Blutampfer, Löwenzahn
und Portulak – und ganz wichtig: ...
... Giersch, Zipperleinkraut.
Schmeckt wie Kohlrabi, Möhre, Petersilie.
Der Giersch soll bei Rheuma
und Erkältungen helfen.
Sein Vitamin-C-Gehalt ist viermal
höher als der von Zitronen.
Die Kräuter werden zerkleinert,
mit Rapsöl vermischt
– und dann mit Ringelblumen
und Tomaten verfeinert.
Also, da tu ich meine ganze Seele in die
Schüssel oder in den Kochtopf reinwerfen
und ich muss mich selber erfreuen.
Und diese Düfte ... also, mit allen Sinnen
zu arbeiten, das ist das Entscheidende,
das ist auch das Erfolgsrezept.
Auch Annika Krause möchte das
Kräuterwissen zurück in den Alltag bringen.
Die ausgebildete Pflanzenheilkundlerin bietet
Wildkräuterwanderungen in Berlin an.
Denn auch in Großstädten
wachsen zahlreiche Wildkräuter
– so wie das Knopfkraut,
auch als Franzosenkraut bekannt.
Dieses Kraut kann uns halt auch stärken.
Es hat sehr viel Eisen,
sehr viel Kalzium, Magnesium,
aber wirklich wichtig ist vor allem das Eisen.
Das schönste Kompliment ist, wenn die Leute
nach ’ner Wildkräuterwanderung so
durch die Gegend gehen und immer gucken,
was da alles auf der Erde ist
und was sie wofür nutzen können.
Das ist so ’n bisschen unser Beitrag zu ...
die heimische Natur wieder
mehr wertzuschätzen und dadurch auch zu
schützen – und keinen Golfrasen
in ’nem Garten anzulegen.
Wichtige Regeln beim Sammeln:
Stark befahrene Straßen meiden und nur die
Pflanzen pflücken, die man kennt.
Mit ihrem Start-Up „Kruut“ stellt Annika
Krause auch Essenzen aus Wildkräutern her.
Das alte Wissen über die heimische
Pflanzenwelt kommt bei der Gruppe an.
Ich glaube, dass gerade als junger Mensch
einem das gar nicht so bewusst ist in der
Stadt, wenn man da aufwächst, wie ...
was für ’ne Vielfalt eigentlich
das an Wildkräutern bietet.
Seit ich auch mit Wildkräutern koche,
was ich schon mache,
ist meine Mutter auch sehr viel beeindruckter
von mir und ich konnte halt so ...
ja, die ganzen Gerichte aufwerten.
Wie vielseitig Wildkräuter sind,
weiß auch Peter Franke.
Er verwendet sie nicht nur zum Kochen,
sondern macht sie haltbar
und verarbeitet sie zu Marmelade, Gelee,
Sirup, Essig und Öl.
Seine Faszination für heimische Kräuter
möchte er an seine Gäste weitergeben.
In dieser Konsumgesellschaft,
wo alles so verfügbar ist,
wo man nicht mehr auf die Gesundheit
so stark achtet,wie wir eigentlich sollten,
sollten die Wildkräuter wirklich ’ne
neue Rolle und Bedeutung
in der gesamten Gesellschaft spielen.